hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm in today we have a
crazy way to counter-attack the King's
gambit Kings game but being my favorite
opening in chess starts with the movie
for a 5 and then f4 and then we get to
the crazy move and that is f5 hopefully
after this video if you like playing the
King's game but you'll have a better
understanding of how to attack this line
if you see it if you're black and you're
crazy enough you may just want to try it
if you ever see your opponent play the
Kings game but there's a lot of
different traps you can play in this and
if your opponent's not ready for it too
it could catch them off guard hopefully
you guys enjoy this video I have a lot
of other videos on the King's game it on
all the variations that you could seize
to definitely check those out as well
but one of the first traps that you'll
see in this opening is they may not know
how to take back correctly and they may
look at this and say yeah I was already
gonna give up my F pawn here so I'll go
ahead and take your center pawn here on
e5 that would be a big mistake and not
everyone's gonna fall for that obviously
but it's always good to know what you
should do if your opponents do fall for
a trap or make a mistake in a chess game
from here black plays the move Queen to
h4 you can already see what we are
attacking here after check if they play
g3 then we're going to be forking their
rook here on h1 so it doesn't matter how
they really block this we're gonna take
the rook here on h1 if they don't play
pawn to g3 not a lot of other great
options King to e2 queenie 4 check get
the bishop involved into the game maybe
King over here to g3 check with the pawn
if they don't maybe they play d4 check
but then when they play the King we come
back here with Bishop to e5 check as
well so at the other day it's gonna be
extremely bad if they take with this
pawn here on e5 now more than likely
they will take with their other pawn
which they should so that's what we're
gonna be looking at mostly in this video
is if they take with their pawn here on
f5 can't bring our Queen down here to h4
or you can see they solidify solidified
this pawn chain right here and we can't
come over check their King at all so
that is not the move that we're gonna be
playing instead right are you playing
the move Queen to e7 now you could look
at this position and say there's an
in-between move that you could make so
instead of Queen to e7 you could play
Queen to h4 check essentially forcing g3
and then the move Queen to e7 you have
this same position but the pawn here on
g3 now this may look better for black
but I think it's better not to play that
in between moving and I'll show you why
because after the move Queen to e7 one
of the threats that you have is your
opponent taking here on e5 because they
may think that you could just take here
if you look at this board they're up to
pawns and material you haven't taken any
material they've just gobbled up pawns
here that you could take with your queen
here on e5 and they could play Bishop
here to e2 or potentially their queen to
e2 so you can't just take here your
queen is now pinned
they can exchange material off pretty
easily here even if you were to exchange
right here your whites up and material
and they may feel like this is a very
good game that they have unfortunately
for whites
that's not how black is going to take
they're not gonna come here to e5 and
check black is gonna come here to h4
check and then same as before we see
pawn to g3 Queen swings over here to e4
and you can already see that the rook is
gonna fall here on h1 so that's a little
bit different than if we started with
that in between move and play Queen to
h4 they play g3 stop and that Queen
comes back here to e7 and if they take
we don't have that option of coming here
to h4 it is stopped by the pawn here on
g3 so that's why I wouldn't play the
in-between move as soon as they play
pawn takes here on f5 I was just going
to play Queen to e7 alright so let's
look at some of the options that you
could see after the move Queen to e7
when the first logical moves is Knight
to f3 very common line in the Kings game
it pretty much in all chess to bring
your knight here to f3 develops another
piece attacks this square here on e5 and
also prepares once the light square
Bishop get involved to castle on the
King side so I think this would be
pretty common for you to see you're
gonna continue with Knight to c6 you
want to develop as much pieces as you
can in the board and this also lays
another trap because they may look at
this and say I can just go ahead and
take with my knight here it's protected
by the pond so maybe they take here take
here same thing as before Queen takes
Queen takes and they may feel that you
have to exchange you've probably seen
this before now but we don't have to
take with our Queen here on e5 we're
gonna be doing the same thing as as
before so going over here to e4 you
start to recognize the pattern here so
they don't have to take with their
Knights or even if we do take with our
knight they don't have to take with
their pawn they could try some some
other stuff now we are threatening mate
here so that they they have to do
something they can't just play Knight to
c3 and try to develop material that's
mate right there they don't have
anywhere to move this is double check
they have to move their King and the
King can't go anywhere because of the
night so we are representing it a real
threat here so they may decide ok
instead of the pond taking well I'm
gonna be aggressive myself so Queen down
here to h4 that's not necessarily going
to work because you could just play g6
in this spot and doesn't really matter
how they they continue from here they
don't have a lot of good moves now if
they take this pawn here because many
times they're looking for the pawn to
come down to g7 with the discovered
attack and recognizing like hey the pawn
just can't take here because the Queen
can just capture this rook here on h8
but if they take with their pawn
they're going to lose again because
we're still representing that serious
threat now Knight to d3 the only
difference is the King can now come to
d1 but it is going to be checkmate in 1
after Knight - f - there's no way to
stop that so I definitely can't take
with there
here on a g6 they could take the nights
here but then they're just gonna lose
their queen so that's really not an
option
can't bring the Queen here so really the
in this spot that they're gonna be
looking to to take with their pawn but
that's as we just saw that that's not
gonna be really good so don't want to
take with their Knight right here
another option after we play Knight to
c3 they could play Bishop to e2 from
here we're playing d6 solidifying the
pawn Chang also opening up for this
light square bishop to take the material
here on f5 remember we gave up two pawns
in material at the beginning if they
wanted to take it so we gave that first
pawn up and then they can always take
this second pawn but we're gonna be
getting that material back pretty
quickly here so if they Castle on the
Kings side you could say Bishop takes on
f5 and we are even in material if they
decide now or instead of castling to go
ahead and take that second pawn here on
e5 that's fine we could just recapture
with our pawn on e5 we have the e pawn
we can get our Bishop here to f5 we can
castle on the Queen side in this
position I wouldn't recommend and
cancelling on the King side there's so
much going on on the King side but
definitely a good position that you have
here if they don't take with their pawn
that they could see this pawn to d6 and
this opens up for a pin on the knight so
they could play Bishop here to b5 that's
fine just Bishop takes here on f5 so all
those are fine indeed if instead of the
bishop coming here to e2 they could also
play the move pawn takes here on e5 we
saw that Knight taking here probably not
the best move but they could play with
their pawn taking here and then we're
just going to take with our nights after
the knight takes right here and then
just we're gonna come up here and take
with our queen now if they come Queen to
e2 I don't really like taking yet
because they could just recapture and we
don't have the the best position instead
I recommend playing d6 this does a
couple things one is once they take we
recapture but we have a better position
because we have a central pawn here on
e5 we can on our next move
take with our Bishop here on c5 so if
you know there's going to be an exchange
think about the the best way that you
can have the setup you want because
after this exchange you can see it's
gonna take two moves
we could play pawn to d5 to have a
central pawn here and then Bishop to f5
just much better to play something like
after Queen to e2 that that pawn to d6
so just an option if they don't play
Queen to e2 they could play Bishop here
to e2 that's fine we're just continue to
develop our pieces Knight to f6 get our
pawn and bottom to the game Bishop here
to f4 that's that's the strategy that
we're going to be going for for all the
options if they after we play the move
Knight to c6 next version that you could
see is the Queen comes down here to h5
check and black really needs to play
King to d8 and we looked at a previous
example where g6 saved the day but that
was when the knight was here on e5 and
we were threatening the mates with the
double check here on d3 don't have the
knight there the Knights back here on a
b8 so G 6 is not gonna cut it after the
pawn takes yeah we could have a
discovered attack here take material on
f4 but doesn't matter Bishop to e2
Black's gonna have to play King to d8 so
don't do that if they play this Queen
down here to h5 just play King to d8
you're not really looking to castle on
the King side anyway so it doesn't
really matter too much that you can't
castle anymore
yes eventually you would like to castle
on the Queen side which you can't do
anymore but you have King safety you're
gonna be pushing forward at some point
with your deep on you can recapture here
you could play Knight to f6 force the
Queen back they will have moved their
Queen a couple moves you're going to be
completely fine in this position maybe
they take with their pawn on e5 you take
with your Queen Bishop here to e2 Knight
to f6 maybe they bring their Queen back
here to h4 pinning down our Knights
Knight to c6 here we're talked about get
dark square Bishop involved into the
game push the pawn up here you can
attack the pawn here on f5 you can't
castle but you can still get your rook
involved
to the game you have this open file here
on the e-file this F file as well
and you can see from white standpoint
they're gonna need to get their knight
involved into the game we have both of
our Knights evolved into the game their
dark square Bishop is not involved into
the game and their King is still in the
center of the board and it's gonna be
pretty dangerous for them to try to
castle on the King side as well it's
gonna take quite a few moves to castle
on the Queen side so she still have a
lot of attacks going on here and once we
take this material back on f5 we're
still going to be even in material
laceration we are gonna look at is if
the knight comes to c3 we're going to
marry that with our own Knight to c6
slight difference is that in this spot
if they play pawn to e5 we can't play
our normal hey you took here we're gonna
play Queen to h4 because after g3 Queen
to e4 forking the rook here they just
take our Queen so don't do that that
would be a huge blunder in chess so
instead of the Queen coming here to h4
we're just gonna take with our Queen
here on e5 if they play Bishop that's
fine then Knight to d4 puts a lot of
pressure on our opponents you know maybe
they play Knight to f3 and then Knight
takes pawn captures and then we can
either take with our queen here on f5
and you can see there their King sides
completely blown up you could play
Bishop here to c5 so you have a lot of
options maybe instead of Knight to f3
they play d3 but you can see they just
don't have a lot of great squares Knight
to f6 get our other night involvement to
the game you can get your Bishop here to
b4 how do they really continue in this
spot that we just block off so many of
the critical squares that they want to
go to instead of Bishop here to to e2
same thing as before they could play
Queen to e2 and we could play pawn d6 so
a lot of different options but that is
some crazy opening in the King's gambit
so if you meet the Kings gambit
you won't try it yourself go ahead and
play this f5 let me know what you guys
think in it you know if you play it from
whites standpoint as well make sure that
you know how to play definitely don't
leak capturing here on the e5 square if
you liked this video if you like the
King's game at our other gambits and you
like these videos if you wouldn't mind
pressing that like button and also if
you try out this gambit let me know how
it goes in the comments or if there's
other videos that you would like to see
most of the videos I make our
recommendations from people either in
the comments or via email that people
are sending to me so love the
suggestions keep those coming or if you
have other variations of your favorite
opening and you say hey can you go
through this variation as well
definitely make those videos for you
guys so thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you in the next video